je sais pas être sale mais a comme
partie manip et j'ai grandi dans un
environnement plutôt urbain on met
plutôt à ça tu m'aimes ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un local de l'étape sursauter
dicks puisque j'ai grandi à lyon 9e n'ya
pas très loin d'ici
ça ressemble à ça non pas exactement en
amazonie et j'ai même fait mes études l
insa de lyon à côté de son côté d'ici
donc aujourd'hui effectivement je
raconte des histoires en images
principalement du vivant et je vais
essayer de vous présenter ici comment
les aventures mes aventures de ces
dernières années on modifier
profondément la perception que j'ai de
ce que c'est le sauvage des paysages
autour de nous et où va la biodiversité
dans notre pays en europe
donc quand j'étais petit la nature
grosso modo c'était ça c'est à dire que
la nature égale campagne
c'est ce qu'on voit quand on est dans un
train et qu'on regarde à droite et à
gauche c'est globalement des deschamps
principalement aux monocultures avec
quelques armes entre les deux qui
forment une haie est ce qu on veut
trouver de plus sauvage là-dedans
généralement si ça peut être
potentiellement une vache mal luné mais
la connexion avec la nature
véritablement sauvage est relativement
difficile à dos alors je savais bien moi
j'étais un petit garçon passionné de
tout vécu ce personnage savais que ça
existait j'avais dans ma chambre je me
souviens des posters partout ces espèces
que je me promettais d'aller voir un
jour mais c'était de l'ordre du rêve
c'était très lointain puisque autour de
moi je voyais rien de tout ça ce que je
voyais c'était encore une fois c'était
plutôt ça est ce que je trouve
intéressant avec ce genre d'image c'est
que quand on prend un peu de hauteur sur
nos paysages on se rend compte de
l'impact qu'on a sur cesson au paysage
en france qui est absolument ahurissant
sur un paysage comme ça par exemple faut
quand même s'imaginer qui a pas un
centimètre carré père cap a été déplacé
par l'homme et à part un caillou qui a
été bougé il n'y a pas un arbre qui n'a
pas été plantés parlons donc en fait on
est vraiment en phase sur une partie du
paysage autour de nous de ce qu'on voit
tous les jours ah les paysages qui sont
quand même extrêmement modifié et
anthropiques
alors j'ai une chance à ces
extraordinaires dans ma vie c'est
lorsque j'ai terminé mes études j'ai pu
déterminer à l'étranger peut les voir un
petit peu ce qui se passait ailleurs
chez nous et je suis allé aux états unis
et je suis tombé devant c'est énorme
étendues sauvages américaine avec
notamment par exemple ici c'était la
réserve de pain criaient ce qui se
trouve au nord de san francisco ou
notamment il y avait ces grandes ses
grandes plages de sable à l'infini
complètement sauvage qui était une
rupture totale avec mon imaginaire
collectif d'enfants français ayant
grandi avec une définition des plages
qui est plutôt trouver une place entre
deux serviettes avec des billes parfois
en cailloux et un tracteur qui vient
récolter les mégots le matin avant on
était dans un imaginaire complètement
différent et ça m'a énormément marqué je
me suis rendu compte aussi d'une chose
c'est que jusqu'à dans notre sémantique
dans notre langue française le mot
sauvage est extrêmement négativement
connoté
sauvage en français c'est quasiment une
insulte c'est un mot qu'on retrouve
plutôt chez les politiques quand il
décrit des quartiers sensibles ce genre
de choses vous voyez vous prêtez eu les
mots qui arrive inhumain grossier cruel
rustique et ses pertes alors que le mot
américain au wild
donnaient plutôt la définition de
globalement de la nature ou du la
liberté donc comment peut-on avoir une
relation avec le sauvage quand notre
langue et nos paysages ne vous rappelle
rien de tout ça quand nous éloigne de
tout ça je me suis rendu compte aussi
d'une chose c'est que l'émerveillement
j'avais eu à la découverte de ces
paysages extraordinaires des états unis
et ben en fait c'est émerveillement là
il très anciens sans être espèce là vous
être en face d'une des premières images
du monde
premières images de l'humanité qui
dépeint quoi dans la grotte de lascaux
il ya 20 millions et 27 faune
extraordinaire qui nous en qui nous
remplissent est là vous voyez d europe
des bovins vous voyez des chevaux
sauvages ou défaire par exemple est ce
que j'ai compris plus tard c'est que la
neuroscience l'a bien montré de
multiples reprises quand on se balade en
forêt quand on est devant une montagne
quand on voit l'océan quand on rencontre
ces espaces sauvages on a une sécrétion
de certaines hormones qui font qu'on se
sent bien et ça donc c'est un besoin
physiologique de l'être humain et j'ai
compris aussi assez vite que du coup on
avait trouvé des moyens pour répondre à
ce genre de besoin à la manière dont
quand on a une petite baisse de sucre en
ouvrant une canette de coca et bienfaits
de la même fusée de la même chose avec
notre recherche de nature donc on a
imaginé des lieux qu'on appelle des eaux
par exemple il ya bien d'autres sud de
même bien d'autres exemples où on est
cette nature dans des boîtes pour
pouvoir aller facilement s'y frotter et
consommer nos petits besoins de nature
il va nous faire du bien que soit
conscient ou inconscient ce fac c'est ça
qui est intéressant aussi
alors moi ya quelques années il ya plus
d'une douzaine d'années j'ai décidé de
me lancer dans la production
audiovisuelle pour raconter ces
histoires là et comme je voulais
raconter j'avais pas exactement grandir
en amazonie donc j'avais beaucoup de
choses à apprendre et j'ai fait
évidemment toutes les bêtises possibles
normes et expédition pour prendre
quelques exemples je me suis perdue en
sibérie entre la corée du nord la chine
et la russie dans une réserve à tigre je
suis un gars marché sur un cayman au
costa rica dans la forêt oui pendant la
saison des pluies j'ai appris quelques
aliments aux balades en forêt ou par
exemple
j'étais face à ce rhinocéros au népal
qui a décidé de me courte me courir
derrière et de m'écraser vous n'a pas
réussi c'était des expériences qui ont
contribué à changer fondamentalement ma
perception du sauvage qui est pas
simplement cette carte postale j'ai
compris aussi un truc c'est en rentrant
en france j'étais face à ces paysages là
je me disais c'est quand même des
paysages qui pour nous sont quand même
très très particulier et on s'y est
habitué comme étant comme le prenons
comme étant vraiment la norme devant
nous et j'ai compris aussi plus tard
qu'en fait c'est ce syndrome l'inde
considérer que c'est la norme c'est
quelque chose qui était étudié à la
science qui l'appelle à shifting
baseline syndrome bref c'est quelque
chose dont vous avez entendu parler qui
est un mécanisme qui fait que de
génération en génération on s'habitue à
une appauvrissement des paysages c'est à
dire que chaque enfant qui nait prend le
paysage qu'il a devant lui comme étant
la norme
est alors sur 11 et des sauts de 200 en
200 ans on aurait des chocs mais comme
ça se fait graduellement petit peu comme
une grenouille qu'on plonge dans l'eau
pour qu'on fait qu on fait chauffer tout
doucement on s'en rend pas compte de ça
il ya plein d'exemples à travers le
monde et j'ai décidé de vous en
présenter une quel exemple de l'ecosse
voilà un paysage écossais qui paraît à
la fois aux voyageurs et même aux
écossais comme étant le paysage
classique de l'ecosse
alors que pour nombre d'experts et de
scientifiques on est en face d'un
paysage clairement malade ce paysage là
en réalité il ya quelques années à
ressembler à ça
l'ecosse elle est à la bonne latitude la
latitude la météo l'humilité
comparable à ce qu'on retrouve à
certains endroits du canada et l'ecosse
est l'exemple typique est saisissant
d'un paysage qui a été développée qui a
été de lever qui a été changée pardon du
par l'homme jusqu'au dernier arbre et
ont scié complètement habitué et je suis
persuadé que ce shift in guezzam
syndrome n'a pas de limites en fait on
s'habituera jusqu'aux dernières
parcelles de terre bitume et quand il
n'ya pas de limite et l'exemple de
l'école c'est assez intéressant en la
matière
en revenant aussi en france et dans
notre
sens notre continent je me suis pris à
regarder un peu les paysages
différemment alors j'ai pris deux
exemples ici ils sont par exemple les
rivières on y est habitué à des rivières
qui ressemble comme celle à gauche et le
rhône et qui est une rivière
complètement caréné sur lequel les des
barrages régulier barrage qui empêche
pour les poissons de circuler mais aussi
les sédiments c'est à dire c'est pour ça
que les plages disparaissent et qu'on
fait venir du sable par camion par
container parce que avec des rivières
comme ça on peut plus avoir de de sa b2
et de plages et puis à droite un autre
exemple exemple de la loire suite ce à
quoi devrait normalement ressembler une
rivière donc on s'habitue à des choses
qu'on considère comme la norme alors que
la norme devrait être assez différentes
un autre exemple c'est les forêts la
différence entre une forêt vivante avec
une myriade d'espèces différentes
animales et végétales du bois mort
évidemment parce que la nature en a
besoin myriad d'espèces qui ne vivent
que dans le bois mort par exemple et
puis une plantation plantation d'arbres
et pas beaucoup plus de biodiversité que
dans un champ de maïs absolument par une
forêt
et en prenant un petit peu de recul sur
la france et sur l'europe je me suis
rendu compte qu'on était vraiment en
fait quelque chose d'assez étonnant et
dont on parle finalement assez peu c'est
là qu'on avait à la fois des territoires
que sont les grandes plaines agricoles
les grandes plaines urbaine dont on sait
on est en chute libre au niveau de la
vie sur terre déjà entendu parler
-80% d'insectes sur certains secteurs
avec -10% ce serait un que ce serait
grave -80% on sait pas du tout où on va
on sait qu'avant 60% d'oiseau en raison
de sa dans les îles en a vu la
disparition des moineaux par exemple et
puis en même temps à l'autre bout du
spectre on à l'exact inverse qui se
passe avec une renaissance des montagnes
notamment
dans en montagne ce qu'on voit c'est un
retour massif de la forêt et un retour
espèces on pensait jamais qu'ils
allaient revenir et en fait est
intéressant c'est que ce ce retour là il
s'observe au niveau de l'europe entière
un à la fois comme j'ai dit des
territoires qui sont sacrifiés au niveau
de la vie sur terre pour une
productivisme acharné et en face on a
des territoires qui sont un petit peu
abandonné est ce qu'on voit en europe
c'est un retour massif d'espèces de
grandes espèces charismatique qui
profitent des niches laissées par
finalement notamment cette agriculture
qui peut parfois pas se développer en
montagne puisque on a besoin de jean
ries importante ne permet pas par
exemple et donc on a des espèces
extraordinaire la la ces chiffres qui
datent de quelques années mais qui
montrent que pour certaines espèces les
grandes espèces man et co rédacteur les
ours il ya les vannes s'ouvrent sur
l'a10 puis fois plus de ressources ici
en europe et aux états unis il ya des
chiffres très est très important et très
étonnant sur notre faune européenne qui
est pas celle qu'on s'imagine quand on y
pense généralement on a donc un grand
retour de ces espèces là
dans certains espaces
donc là c'est une carte de france et une
carte scientifique fait par une équipe
de scientifiques tentent à identifier on
sont les lieux naturalité en france où
est-ce qu'on en est et bien c'est sans
surprise qu'on voit que ça se passe pas
très bien fait en région parisienne on a
une france qui est un petit peu coupé en
deux avec voilà le nord-ouest qui est
quand même extrêmement cultive et ce qui
sort là dedans toute façon très
clairement c'est les montagnes c'est des
lieux quand il est difficile
d'accès et qui ont permis à cette vie de
revenir aujourd'hui fortement
et je vais vous prendre un exemple que
je trouve assez passionnant qui est très
prolifique très proche d'ici dans le
vercors je prends la réserve des hauts
plateaux du vercors qui n'était
d'ailleurs pas une réserve avant de le
devenir
un petit enfant qui se baladait ya 60
ans avec son papa sur les hauts plateaux
d'abord il n'y aurait quasiment pas vu
de forêt mais quasiment plus de forêts
et surtout il y avait plus aucune espèce
animale c'est à dire qu'il y avait plus
de bouquetins et les plus de vautours et
puis de serre on pourrait continuer
comme ça la liste très longtemps
aujourd'hui on est soixante ans plus
tard et regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui quand je me balade avec les
deux petits garçons sur les hauts
plateaux voilà ce qu'on peut voir
et donc ça montre bien que ce retour est
possible et ce retour il a été dû à quoi
il a été due à la fois bien certaines
espèces qui sont revenus tout seul sauf
qu'on ne leur ai rien demandé c'est le
cas évidemment du loup qui fait parler
qui fait créer boutique fit couler
pardon beaucoup d'encre qui est revenu
tout seul d'italie n'a pas encouragé à
revenir mais il est revenu tout seul et
il est revenu parce qu'il a trouvé un
territoire qui était prêt pour lui
toutes les autres espèces était remis
certaines réintroduite alors ce qui est
marrant aussi fait que certaines espèces
ont été réintroduits plus tôt par le
milieu de la chasse qui avait envie de
pouvoir chasser introduit le faire par
exemple mais aussi par du côté des
écologistes des parcs naturels par
exemple le bouquetin dont le vautour qui
ont été réintroduits là dedans au delà
du fait de pouvoir de nouveau
s'émerveiller et de lancer une chute
baseline dans l'autre sens vers de
s'habituer à et ongles sa la norme est
pas qu'on avait avant est ce qui est
important c'est que toutes ces espèces
amène la fonctionnalité en fait on sait
aujourd'hui si on ça démontre airs
démontrer que toutes ces espèces sont
comme des différentes parties d'un
moteur qui sans ça et en fait ça
fonctionne pas et puis si on regarde un
petit peu dans le futur
rien est impossible de dire aujourd'hui
ce qui manque sur ce genre de deux
espaces là c'est les grands architectes
lorsque les spécialistes et les grands
architectes de nos paysages c'étaient
les grands herbivores les grands
herbivores c'est eux qui ont façonné la
france partie de la france comme on la
connaît
et donc les chevaux sauvages de bisons
européens le rock sont des espèces qui
aujourd'hui aurait une fonctionnalité
extrêmement importante
enfin je voulais terminer avec avec
cette image qui est une image faite lors
d'une réintroduction d'un vautour
envoyer leur garder les enfants qui
comprennent immédiatement le pot 2 de
tout ça et j'espère que cette
présentation vous aura éveillé sur
peut-être un regard différent pour
pouvait avoir sur les paysages qui sont
autour de vous qui sont sont pas
toujours dans un état écologique
optimale et puis aussi vous montrer que
quand on dessert les mains qu'on a bien
souvent autour du cou de la nature elle
peut revenir de façon très puissante et
aussi avec les pleins d'espoir merci
beaucoup